and I have a special guest I have ala
fua with us who just finished his draw
against Wesley um his game against
Wesley so in a draw Anda welcome back to
the studio I think you missed only one
day with us but actually I have no idea
what do you feel after the first event
world I mean sorry St Louis rapid and
Blitz tournament um how did it go for
you the last day and what are your
emotions after yeah it was a good start
the last day but I didn't didn't play
really good I actually was very close to
get Take the Lead mhm but I lost two
crucial games against Fabiano and Maxim
so that was the end the summary of the
tournament so I finished fifth it was
not really what I wanted of course but
um it's it was decent and now I'm more
focusing on the classical and of course
yes now we have single cup and let's say
you were the winner of the previous one
uh you had two days to recover after the
first event so how do you feel what did
you do during those days yeah um I
mainly wanted to switch to classical mod
my brain and because we play how do you
do it it's not easy I think but I think
we played a good game today and um it
was important game also for you because
I lost to wle in Romania first game with
white even so so I had to be careful and
I chose the very solid opening so it was
a I think decent game yeah I think this
game was also important because you you
are still fighting for the sport in the
candidates tournament and it's all about
the rating as well so I'm sure you
didn't want to give some rating points
to Wesley today so let's see what
happened yes how did you manage to
equalize I think so comfortably yeah he
chose the very solid line of course also
because he it's first game and there's
no need to take so much risk and he is a
very fashionable line now and he choose
Bishop D2 I have some games here even
with black and I think this is the best
line there's not so much thing to talk
about I think here after E5 I
comfortably equalize because if he takes
the pawn it's always compensation here I
think even Bishop A6 and um you have two
Bishops yeah he has Pawn for two Bishops
but his King is always weak and he has
trouble to defend the E2 Pawn so if he
goes for instance Rook e one rookie um I
think even Queen D1 takes Rook E8 Bishop
D4 and Bishop E2 just mhm
so he he tried to he was thinking he was
taking a lot his time here and I think
tried to even bail out because if I take
my put my pieces out go as in the game
Bishop E6 F6 maybe I could I cannot
never be better but he just forced the
draw here with Bishop C6 and Knight A5
and I always could go for the opposite
color bishop and this is always the draw
so King F1 and yeah he Chang it wasn't
very clean game Yes actually yes it was
a exactly very clean like grandm Master
game uh do you think if you were in the
place of Wesley playing with white
pieces would you try to take more risks
considering the situation yeah probo
maybe he was surprised with my C5
opening Choice um I I play all kind of
moves here so maybe he didn't spend so
much time yes maybe he's in prepared for
so I would not say that he wanted to
make draw today but it was just how the
game went Soh
uh you said that you really needed to
switch to this classical games and um
let's say how important is it do you
mean that sometimes you can make just
quick moves and it can completely change
the situation like blit sometimes you
have to just take your time to make sure
and but when you play a lot of Blitz and
Rapid games it's not easy to switch so
so what do you speak to yourself like or
do you put your hands you know somewhere
don't make a you should always it's a
mental thing and they have to but these
guys are very good at switch
yeah this this for sure I heard that you
were in the Hall of Fame yesterday and
you bought some something in the shop
tell us a little bit about this
experience yeah it was um was I mean we
were we are always going from the Hall
of Fame to the playing but there's never
time to see everything but it's very
interesting there's everything written
about the Fisher FK match and and the
shop is pretty cool I never been to
chess shop like this oh yes okay yeah
because they have many cool pieces
actually uh some even very expensive but
there is always affordable also but
there is some very cool expensive pieces
you can see also did they have already
some Black Friday discounts I I didn't
see it but hopefully next time they will
yes okay 20% off this is what is
happening right now not bad not bad for
for our viewers also don't forget to
come by and check the the shop of the
vess Hall of Fame yes maybe
or you want to have some questions to
Ala uh no questions for us just uh get
focused and uh well uh good good luck in
the tournament actually good luck in the
rest of your games Ali
Resa and with that I just wanted to turn